عشره اشهر وتتوالى فصول حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بلو وكانها تزداد دراوتني يوما
بعد اخر
تصدر القصف الروسي على مدينه خرسون جنوب
اوكرانيا اخر الانباء وذكر انه اسفر عن
سقوط 10 بين قتيل وجريح وقد اتهم محاكم
خير سنن القوه الروسيه باستهداف المنطقه
عشرات المرات بالمدفعيه والراجمات
الصواريخ والدبابات قائلا ان القذائف
الروسيه ضربت ايضا منشات البنيه التحتيه
ورياض الاطفال والمدارس والمستشفيات
والمتاجر والمصانع والمباني السكنيه
الرئيس الاوكراني
يجري ليس حربا وانما هو ارهاب وقتل بهدف
التخويف والتلذذ على حد قوله وما فتيات
خير سنه تعرض لقصف الروسي تتوالى فصوله
منذ ان استعادتها اوكرانيا وتطلب كيس من
الغرب منذ اسابيع مزيدا من المساعدات
الماليه والعسكريه خلص ليست الوحيده في
قلب المعارك قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
سلاح الجو اسقط مقاتله اوكرانيه وثلاث
مرايات وعشرات الطائرات المسيره في دوناتس
وعند القوات الاوكرانيه صدت عددا من
الهجمات الروسيه على مناطق مختلفه في
المقاطعتين وانه محاولات الجيش الروسي
لاقتحام مدينه باخمود باعت بالفشل رغم
كثافه بقصيها وتقول اوكرانيا ايضا ان
قواتها قتلت عشرات الجنود الروس ودمرت
منظومتين مدفعيه خلال قصفها مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه الزبرجيا وان
المقاتلات الاوكرانيه تنفذ غارات مستمره
على تلك المواقع والمنظمات الصاروخيه
والطائرات المسيره في هذه الاثناء يدور
الحديث في كييف من جديد عن ان سن روسيا
هجوما على اوكرانيا انطلاقا من اراضي
بالروسيه ليس مستبعدا لكن موسكو تنفي ان
يكون التحالف العسكري بين روسيا وبيلا
روسيا مرتبطا بالحرب في اوكرانيا وتقول ان
مهمته تتمثل في صد اي عدوان محتمل ضد
اراضي بيلاروسيا حليفتها